hey this is John de Looney what's up
i'll be--i'll are doing good dude
I'm with my good friend Eric Young she's
been in the Ramsay ecosystem for about
250 years and she's still this beautiful
and we've been waiting for her to come
for weeks and I'm so excited that she's
here she is a coach
she is a creator and she navigates helps
people navigate the choppy waters that
are every day and so I'm blessed I'm
gonna I'm gonna take this opportunity to
learn from her and I can't wait and I'm
glad y'all get to sit in on this so
what's up oh man everything is awesome
to be here
yeah thanks for having me you bet so
here zona start how did you get into
this ecosystem how did you how did the
message of Ramsey how did this idea of I
want to walk and help people like how
did you get to be this well I was in
debt I mean my husband and I we got
married and we had a whole lot of debt
we did all the things that everybody
does we got the student loans and got
the job we decided oh let's get a house
we needed cars we had the kids and
really early in our relationship we
realized we didn't have enough money
every month okay what do we do and so he
was actually on the road he was you know
with his carpool partner and they
started listening to Dave Ramsey on
radio and so he was the one who came
home and said hey you got to listen to
this guy and I was like I don't feel
like doing that I mean and you know I
realized that I needed to when he
started saying okay so we've got
problems like we don't know how we're
gonna pay all these bills we've got way
too much you know month left at the end
of the money you know what I mean like
this is this is a problem and so he
encouraged me to start listening and
then you know I have to admit I got
hooked and the first thing that my
husband had to do it was take the credit
cards away from me because as an
engineer I would go out to lunch with
friends and I didn't want to share oh
goodness I don't have dollars for lunch
or you know I didn't have the cash for
that and I hid that from my husband
and when we had to have that real talk
where we just sat down and said what's
really going on why are we not making
progress
was one of the biggest things so so you
did this cause dissension in your heart
and in your marriage or did y'all have
to just figure it out I just had to
breathe and get over myself I mean
honestly I mean I think part of this
journey is just knowing that none of us
are perfect and when somebody calls us
on that carpet we have to be honest with
ourselves but no very few people are
yeah what was it about you that said or
maybe it was him or maybe it was the the
alchemy of between the two of you what
was it that let you hear that well we
didn't want to be like our family like
we love our family dearly but both of us
came from single-parent households where
finances were struggle so the truth of
the matter is is that if I wanted
something different I was gonna have to
do something different and we were
falling into the same trap of you know
paying debts and things like that you
know and so we just needed something
different and and that's kind of when we
draw you know drew the line in the sand
and said let's change our family tree
because otherwise we'll lead down the
same path that were previous to us and
we just didn't want that I want everyone
I normally don't do this in these but
that was important if you do an
inventory of your life you know what you
think you know the people you surround
yourself with and you know the actions
that get you through every day just look
around your life and if that's the life
that you want congratulations I haven't
met many people who look around and say
I'm good with my thoughts and my actions
and my community my the the people of
our relationships our law in my life
that's big so tell me about the the move
from being able to hear from somebody
looking in the mirror and saying I got
to make some changes inside my heart and
and the the way I'm living my life and
what led you from an engineer to know
how look sit sit at a table with
somebody and help them walk their
journey yeah well I had to play some
stupid tax right in the beginning
honestly because you know we tripped
over ourselves in that journey even
after that initial you know come to
Jesus meeting you know what I mean we
just so we we had moments where we just
didn't still didn't have enough money to
get the car fixed and so we went further
into debt and we have moments where you
know we were frustrated
you know made decisions we wish that we
hadn't and but the whole point was we
took Financial Peace University we saw
Dave Ramsey live when he came into our
city and we started to get a clue and
take action on that and so it took us
five years to get out of about $90,000
in debt but we decided we didn't want
that life anymore and I wanted to help
other people do the same thing I didn't
want people to take five years I wanted
to see what was it gonna take for them
then I trip over themselves like I did
and what are the resources and tools how
can I support them and encourage them in
that journey that's that would get extra
training or did you just take your life
lessons to go back to school like what
was the what was the gap from engineer
to I honestly went through coach
training with Dave Ramsey's team I
brought my husband in 2006 we got
trained and I caught the vision of
making a difference for somebody else
and that was huge because and I didn't
honestly do a whole lot of other
training other than reading the books
going to you know conferences and
learning about personal finance and it
starts with the budget and that's
exactly what they says so we took that
to heart
so one of the things in a mental health
space I think it's important to to point
out if you're suffering from major
depression disorder one of the first
things they will they will do for you is
give you a plan of little wins so let's
say somebody can't get out of bed they
can't can't communicate there they've
got phobias they can't the goal is to
get a little win is to get a plan and
get a little win get out of bed just
take a shower
that's it you win today and then we're
gonna try again tomorrow I want to go
get tomorrow and there's something about
the budget and there's something about
getting either with your partner or with
an accountability friend and doing
together right and then you get that
little win a little bit in that little
win in a little win so stay tuned
because we're gonna continue this
conversation moving forward but I do
want ask you this before we leave what
if you had to distill down when you look
at somebody and they come to you they
are terrified they are they've done the
yellow pad math and then they they get
that one moment and in my world they do
when they check their husband's search
history and they realize oh I'm not the
only one right or they realize that
they're having another anxiety attack
and they got to say something right or
or or when somebody has that moment what
in your experience you mean there's a
long time
what's what's the step from realization
to action oh that's good I really feel
like the reality check is the big moment
people are so afraid of looking at the
numbers they're terrified that's the
biggest thing people don't want to look
at it they sweep it under the rug they
say I'm not looking at my credit report
I don't want to add up the debt and I
personally think doing that by yourself
it's problematic you know so so doing
that with someone you know making
certain that you're not alone in that
journey and sometimes that's with the
coach and sometimes that's with the
partner or with a friend and knowing
that it there's no judgement right there
it just is we all do things that we wish
we had and we all have a past of money
past and so knowing that one you're not
the only one into that you you can you
don't have to walk that path alone but
looking at the numbers is critical and
you can't go anywhere you can't make any
progress if you don't see the issue
you've got to see it like that and I
tell people that all the time it's not
helping you at all to sweep it under the
rug you know see no evil it doesn't help
you right now and so we've got to look
at it in order to be able to be able to
attack it and find a way out so I mean I
kind of like that my analogy I use is
the the GPS lady I wish she had a name
where we plug in our address to where
we're trying to get to and we're looking
for where we're trying to go guess what
she's got to locate where you are right
now that's what GPS is right like she's
got a locate where you are or you know
any path will take you anywhere
so she locates where you are and then
she's able to give you a road map to
where you're trying to go and so she
can't even function without knowing your
current location and so how can you
function what you know about getting to
your goals without knowing your present
state that's so it's so vitally
important so and one thing I love about
the work you do was highlighted in of
all places the the last dance series
that came on
I love last answer because it was this
moment that hit me halfway through when
I stepped back and said I'm looking at
Jordan Pippen and Rodman sum of three of
the greatest basketball players of all
time
but they got a head coach a strength and
training coach a nutritionist some of
the helps with security someone who
helps with their routing like you've got
these brilliant minds you've got these
extraordinary athletes and they still
know the importance of leaning on a
professional for to give me a view of
this that I'm not singing yeah
make sure hold me accountable here and
there's something about we've all been
doing budgets or spending money is
probably going to spend money for years
we think we know how to do that the
importance of having a coach I don't
care how good you are I don't care how
smart you're having somebody else walk
alongside you is so critical I've had a
coach my entire time doing this work so
the coach had a coach counselor you know
what I mean and and I listened to Dave
Ramsey too like it's not I don't just
because I got trained or just because I
did 20,000 a few classes doesn't mean
that I know it all so I'm listening for
what are the things that he's saying
every single time I listen I hear
something new but also you know I'm
packing my own baggage with my own coach
I had a financial coach who looked at my
stuff you know even after we were out of
debt you know to help me with business
and so I meet people to lean into so
that they can call me on my crap yep you
know so that they can help me be honest
and true and take my life to the next
level because you know if I'm
encouraging people to do the same thing
I need to know how that works I need to
continue to stay engaged on that - yeah
right I have something to say I'm gonna
say nothing at the end of that
hey this is dr. John - Loney thanks for
being with us we're gonna continue the
conversation with the one and only Eric
Young check back with us at the next
videos subscribe click in follow us at
all the buttons wherever the the
internet guys whatever talk to you soon
take care have fun see ya